Film Courage: From your Park on the Lot website you have
a [blog] post that you wrote in 2015
Six Things Your TV Spec Script Needs To
Stand Out and we'd love to hear more about that. Carole Kirschner: Do
I remember all six of them? That's a
year ago but I can't give you some
generals. Your spec script has to be
profoundly memorable what I like to call
blazing hot Greg is not good enough so
the first thing is it has to be
incredibly memorable you have to choose
a concept that is something that people
will be talking about the next day it
also has to be really really really
really good I just finished reading
fifty spec scripts for my CBS program
just good isn't good enough there there
were plenty that we're good but it has
to be blazing hot has to be exceptional
and one of the things that makes it
exceptional is a concept where you're
taking a risk you're just taking a risk
you're going outside of just a typical
kind of show typical kind of television
series and you're really trying to go
deeper deeper on the concept level
deeper with your characters and I just
read a script last night that we end
that didn't make it into the into the
next round
it was well-written but it was a
procedural that was just a typical
procedural with a well-written but
typical protagonist and it was a
different sort of environment than we
different workplace than we normally see
and it was fine but it didn't make it
wasn't exceptional it didn't get you
excited when you read it tell me what is
typical that's that's fascinating to me
what about it wasn't Walter White mmm
okay what wasn't Walter White the
character wasn't that interesting it was
a female it was a young woman who was
going against what her family
wanted to do this thing in a man's world
we've only seen that a hundred thousand
times and she she she had something that
she was passionate about but it didn't
reveal enough about her it wasn't a
character you know Walter White had
layers and layers and layers this
character had a lid number to make sure
the show you've selected to speck on is
going to be on the air for a few years
yes I don't want it to be too new you
don't want it to be too old around you
want it just right as a as in a show
that's the second or third season yes
it's important that you don't put all
this work and energy into a spec script
that you can only use for 30 minutes
because a show gets canceled it
shouldn't be so new that we don't know
whether or not it's going to come back
it shouldn't be so old that people have
read it have read every single possible
configuration of that show I saw for my
CBS project I saw somebody write a
Criminal Minds that shows been on the
air for more than ten years don't do
that don't I hate to see people who put
so much time and energy and effort in
blood and sweat and tears into doing a
spec and then only being able to use it
for 30 minutes because the show went off
the air and so really the sweet spot is
a show that's been on the air for two
seasons we know it's kind of a hit and
going into the third season now there's
some exceptions for that when a show
comes out of the gate as a huge hit like
Empire you can pretty much be assured
that it's going to be on the air for a
while which it is and will be but just
to be safe
second year third year second season
third season that's what I recommend in
addition to how long it's been on the
air you want to make sure that the
numbers are strong the other reason to
wait for the second season is so that
people in the business will have had a
chance to have seen the show sometimes
people write shows that are so obscure
that our BBC shows that nobody's
watching that it's hard to appreciate
the spec because we don't know the show
just to go off-topic for a second Carole
where could someone go to look at the
ratings for a show there's a couple of
places you can go to TV by the numbers
comm you can go to actually if you just
google it if you do a search TV ratings
there will be four or five websites that
will come up that will tell you what the
ratings are you can also just google the
name of the television show and then
picked up renewed or cancelled and
there's a whole website that just deals
with renewed or cancelled okay
interesting I did not know that number
four so show runners and executives need
to have actually seen the show how do
you know which ones hint if it's a
critically acclaimed or getting good
reviews it's most likely being watched
any show with buzz okay any show that
has buzz that's getting good numbers or
even if it's not getting good numbers
but it's getting a lot of critical
acclaim like Jane the virgin has not
gotten good numbers but is sort of a
critical darling then you know that
executives and showrunners have read it
know the show you want them as I said to
know the show so that they can evaluate
your material here's here's another sort
of inside tip don't write a spec for a
show that's not very good there's
certain shows that have been on the air
a long time but they don't have depth
they aren't interesting they're just
crowd pleasers that will not show off
your writing ability you want to show
that is textured and layered and
interesting and has depth to show your
writing ability can you can you name a
few shows sure you have texture sure
well there was Breaking Bad which
doesn't help anybody now because if you
have a Breaking Bad I'm sad for you
there is certainly the Americans but the
Americans is going off the air mr. robot
is really good and interesting and Laird
masters of sex
I think veep is funny as a comedy
Silicon Valley as funny as a comedy I
think that shows like I'm just I'm going
by the Network show too
shameless although shameless has been on
too long but it's that kind of a show
where there's there's more to it than
just what's on the surface number 5 your
script can't be too soft make it edgy
edgy edgy ok so you don't want you want
to swing for the fences you want to take
a big risk you want to do something that
that is really edgy that is really sort
of on the per if the parameter of
everyday and is moving into the
extraordinary
that is pretty that's pretty vague I
know but take a risk do something that
is unexpected
that's what edgy is - it's unexpected it
goes to a dark place when you don't
expect it to go to a dark place it goes
to a funny place when you don't expect
it to go to a funny place it's what you
want is to surprise somebody when
they're reading the script where they go
here's the bottom line
let me read something that I didn't see
it coming
that will get you that will get you
noticed a strong memorable concept and
somewhere at least once in your script
where wow I didn't see that coming but
again not so but still keeping within
the world of that show and the reality
of that show so again I think we were
talking about Silicon Valley you're not
going to have aliens land that is risky
that is too risky don't go outside
of what what is the reality of the world
the other thing and I might not have
mentioned it is if you have a show
that's called the Carmichael show let's
say which is on NBC if the stars name is
in the title then you need to make your
spec about the star you aren't going to
get very far if you pick a character
that is rarely seen to do the whole
episode about as somebody said a long
time ago
it's called Roseanne because it's about
Roseanne so that's just a thing to keep
in mind it's interesting to explore in
some way the the B characters but you've
got to pay attention to your a character
so if the whole show becomes about Becky
and all the things going on in her life
and Roseanne just in the background it's
a problem yes it's a big problem exactly
edgy though I see now that stuff's
really pushing the boundaries that get
used to especially 80s television for
all this yes 80s kids out there but when
is it still too edgy for the world that
we're in now which it seems like pretty
much anything we'll go these days but
how do you know you've kind of not not
even just aliens landing but I mean just
something like yucky that's a little
sick that's taking it too far
I think that I I read a script where I
went ooh
yeah because somebody was describing
something that was so sexual and and
weirdly special I went whoa no no no no
no no and being sexual is fine to me you
know I that is I don't have a problem
with that but this went way over the
edge and then it was like anything that
makes you go you or it if you write
something like that and the people that
are reading it for you before you send
it out go ooh then
check it out okay because as soon as
somebody has that reaction it's over
right and I think people have different
levels it's true they do yeah they do
but so if you get someone else who maybe
is more squeamish because there's some
people I could see just go any which way
and yeah I think it's fine but yeah so
maybe have I would show it to a couple
of different people with different
levels of as you say squeamishness and
see what kind of reaction you get if all
three of them go Jim it's just over the
edge
it's over the top make sure it's
something you can write the hell out of
yes it has to be a show you love that
you love that you can't wait to write it
people often have agents or managers or
friends tell them this is a show it's
the best show that's on right now you
should write it
you should only write it if you love it
and you can write the hell out of it
you have the voices of the characters in
your head you have a great idea for it
now that doesn't mean that you should
write something that it's in its first
year or that's in its tenth year or that
is not very well made but it doesn't
have to be what everybody else is
writing write something that you cannot
wait to write and then write the hell
out of it